the way i write is i don't do every line
but i will have
parts of the joke that signify the
beginning middle and end
and so my whole goal with the joke is to
know the beginning middle and end
so um i'll have the premise first
then it'll start to form and then it's
fully cooked
when it has a middle and it has a big
pop at the end i want
you know when you you don't want it to
like die like that i want that last
laugh
of the joke to be the biggest that's the
goal
so sometimes it's like maybe in the
middle or the beginning
and you have to figure out how to work
towards that laugh instead of starting
there
absolutely you couldn't set it better
yeah
like sometimes you're the first time i
tell it the big laugh will be at the
beginning
and that's the goal going like okay now
i got to figure out what the joke is to
put that laugh
at the end of the joke okay
are you more like writing on stage or do
you pinned a paper
all all on stage all on stage i'll go
with an idea
that either hits me while i'm up there
or i've thought of before
and i will completely write it on stage
conversationally
and um i will work it out and punch it
up on stage
um and or off in my head and then put it
on stage
so all the writing is done on stage and
then when it's fully cooked
i'll know it and i do have a checklist
where i'll have the you know
a couple of words that signify what the
joke is
and then towards the beginning of it
i'll i'll have when the middle forms
i'll put that in
and then the end i'll put that in and
then that's it and then
after that i just put the premise
because i know it but
that's the checklist that's how i do it
it's like i'm um my
format is i'm always looking for a
middle and an end so that
and and and i write that down and i keep
track of that and then it's fully cooked
and ready to
ready to come out of the oven when i get
that laugh at the end and it also paces
in the middle a little bit
i want a few laps in the middle i want
to laugh to get into it
and i want the biggest laugh at the end
do you have an example that you could
like walk us through
yeah like i'll take any joke uh that i
have
like um you know i'll take uh
okay like that this um this divorce joke
i used to have
just because the first one i thought of
um or or the soccer joke
um so it's like i'd start with like the
premise
this old soccer joker like you know i
tried to like soccer i did you know it's
just nobody scores
um you know americans will be like
scoring it's like
the most thing that i'll the most
that'll happen in stock is every 10
minutes there'll almost be a goal
so i get a little laugh at the beginning
like saying like soccer sucks
right so some people will laugh whatever
i'll rift that part or something
whatever
feeling whatever the show is um nobody
scores americans like
scoring some passion there and then
i will go uh you know then i'll get uh
you know
the only uh what will happen the only
thing that happens every 10 minutes
there will
almost be a goal someone almost scores
right
set up right there that's why soccer
fans are so violent
that's why they're soccer hooligans
because they never get a chance to
celebrate at the game
so they're all pent up and frustrated
and then they leave the match and punch
each other into place
because they just had gold blue balls
for two and a half hours
boom then i'm gonna laugh there then i
go the only thing that'll make soccer
fun is that there was a blind guy in the
sidelines with the gun
and he was just randomly firing onto the
field boom boom boom so
laugh there and then i go into the
crescendo then i go
you know europeans they hate when you
criticize soccer you know and then i'll
do an impersonation of a swedish guy or
german guy you don't like soccer because
you're american and you're not good at
it whatever
and then i go really magnus you know
lucky you are american athletes
not fun like soccer and this is the last
chunk the biggest laughs
um do you know what happened if black
americans started playing soccer
can you imagine like you know our
athletes there would be no world cup you
know
and then i go can you imagine okay it's
the first game first italy
here comes guido he passes into luigi
luigi back to guido
but oh my god here comes la dame lee and
tomlinson
you know he's juggling six soccer balls
he passes it to lebron james
who kicks a goal into another soccer
stadium in another
country to win four games at the same
time
and at that point it's like it's
laughter it's laughter and that's the
you know it's all the same premise and i
found each
little bits of that until it was all
plugged in
obviously i can't put the act out in the
middle
i can't put that whole black imagine if
black kids love
soccer like they do you know you know
what the premise is i can't put that in
the middle
because it has a big act out to it it
has a crescendo of laughs
so i feel a couple pacing a couple of
pacing
punches with a blind guy in the
sidelines the uh you know the
gold blue balls in the middle and then
the little chuckles and premise up top
and there's the joke man and when i
started that i probably started with
um i started with and i remember
actually i started with the line in my
head
going i know why soccer fans are so
violent because nobody scores so they're
frustrated
so that's how that joke started okay so
that was the only laugh i had
and i was like all right and so that
light that laugh
ended up being in the middle and it's a
big laugh um
and then the bigger i found were the
bigger ones at the end and it turned
into a bit and i pushed that one farther
back
developed it and then found like a real
nice christian
you know ending for it and i used to
close on that joke actually for a while
because it used to
it used to hit so big towards the end
and you you
perform it on stage and then like record
it and review it
i should record it it would make it
quicker probably but i don't because
i just memory yeah recording it's great
though because you
you i just can't stand to hear myself
uh and i don't have the patience to sit
through the show again
so uh i forget a lot of it takes a
lot longer but i do recommend recording
it yeah
put your especially with technology now
your iphone or
just record it listen to it later for
sure i know louis does that
i know a lot of guys who write on stage
do that you know louie writes on stage i
believe and it's like it
it's just it's great to do it that way
if you love comedy as much as we do here
at hot breath
click the subscribe button to join the
hot breath verse and then watch more
videos to get even more comedy tips